hey everyone welcome to this video just  a short video to remind you of something  yeah my English repertoire the one that  was released on just 24 back in i think  it was September which is available on  jesibl as well yeah this is God  introductory offer to get to buy  untestable for 9.99 and this is some  yeah running out the end of the year so  if you are intended to buy this  repertoire and as you see there more  than 150 students already who done so if  you intend to buy it it's a good time to  do this now or yeah on the on New Year's  Eve to make sure that you still get the  nine dots 99 offer yeah it will be 1499  in the new year the second thing I  wanted to quickly mention that i will  have those two shows on New Year's Eve  on New Year's i already posted an  announcement video for that earlier the  week so make sure to join on both are  one of those shows yeah around the end  of the year thanks for watching